[Music]
i
clap very well
we today are doing oh hi by the way um
you're listening to
plastic pills voice on the plastic pills
pill pod
we are talking today about more
frankfurt school
if you were with us last week oh wait
last week was a patreon episode
if you're on the patreon you heard last
week where we began
talking about the frankfurt school and i
think the conclusion from that episode
was that hegel caused the holocaust am i
right in saying that
yeah i mean it took us a while to get
there it was a very dialectically
circuitous
route but we all came to the right
conclusion in the end sure
so hegel caused the holocaust uh maybe
nietzsche had a hand in it too
something like that um today
we are moving to you know nazis that are
defeated
we don't need to write about them
anymore um
the eclipse of reason is over
or so you thought but no um now we're
writing about
america and american capitalism so we're
turning to
frankfurt school in the 50s and beyond
and you know the tarot the evils of
capitalism
and uh the effects it has on the psyche
speaking of psyches did you guys watch
this this uh
debate in our in the crumbling empire to
the south
i did not i did it was probably the
greatest spectator sport i've ever seen
and i was torn between high levels of
anxiety
about the fall of rome and what's going
to mean for all of us
and almost overwhelming joy at the sheer
entertainment value of the spectacle so
yeah i heard it was like a real
failed state kind of vibe going on there
i was getting
i was getting king lear vibes but it's
like if king lear
had a boxing match against king lear
from like the third act of
the play oh yeah trump was like
i kid you not like one insult away from
being and my dick's bigger than yours
[ __ ]
like one inch all the way if like chris
wallace hadn't stepped in and been like
okay
you've attacked his son his intelligence
drug habits
enough is enough right and we're
speaking as
as denizens of a city with a crack
smoking mayor
too and even we were citizens of a city
with a crack smoking mare
okay although not all of us are denizens
of a
city of a crack smoking mayor today with
us as a guest
we have um can i call you an adorno
scholar
is that the sure the region of expertise
the regime
cultural historian okay cultural
historian
influenced at least in part by adorno
it's shaolin
hi shaolin hi if you're familiar with
the
the plastic pills cannon i did a video
on the culture industry which was
co-written or or mostly written if we're
being honest
mostly written by shaolin who i've
worked with before so we're excited to
have her here
again to deal with frank for school
thanks for having me on whoo oh and
shalom would you like to
uh mention to our listeners if they go
to your blog which i will link
here if they go there what will they
find and what are what awaits them
sure so my blog is on my website
shaolinvantine.com and
my blog is second as farce and anything
that i do
and related to podcasts or articles i
always throw up there so
people can follow my work if they want
by going there
i should also say shaolin has very good
taste in film uh and
she has a very very long list of all the
movies that you should ever watch
very long list so if you're ever sitting
there on a date night
yeah definitely check that out you
should put
all right i haven't seen that part of
your blog yet oh really i was i think
the first thing i ever saw
anyway it doesn't matter i'll have to
lurk it
okay lurk shannon's sorry
um we finished
i guess where did we leave off guys if
you can help me we
finished talking about benyamin because
he was unfortunately
suicided they're also talking about um
whether or not there's any kind of
normative lessons to be drawn
from critical theory uh particularly
frankfurt school critical theory or if
it's
only going to ever be critical and we
split uh to a certain extent between the
kind of soft liberals
uh as victor and i sometimes pose
ourselves
and you know the more hard-edged these
soft socialists social democrat
liberal socialism and shaolin i'm going
to ask you to fill in
the names that i forget here but what
we've already covered
at least in part usually during the
immediate immediately after
uh the second world war now we're moving
into the 1950s
but benjamin adorno horkheimer
marcusa um who else am i missing in
there
eric fromm carl lowenthal and lowenthal
yeah what's uh there's another guys paul
newman
um neumann
and then we have like the second
generation which includes people like
martin j
and habermas which is pretty significant
and i should probably note that when
people think about the frankfurt school
you know the the initial frankfurt
school was explicitly
marxist and even though they all had
very distinct
uh philosophies but when you get into
the later frankfurt school
like habermas and jonathan and those
um they they tend to go
more liberal uh so yeah
there's a big shift in um the thought
yeah they diverge in various ways don't
they we we kind of spoke about how
how horkheimer after that first guy i
forget his name who
cares about him uh after horkheimer sort
of
like laid down the research program that
kind of lasted
pretty much all the way habermaus was
really the first guy to kind of break
away from that
like really explicitly like of course
there were different positions within
the frankfurt school
and world war ii kind of split them up
and set them all over the place
but habermaus was the one to sort of
explicitly
diverge from horkheimer's research
program
from the 30s i guess eric haynes if
you're listening
this one's for you thanks bro i just
wanted fanboy for a second and say that
i was really happy eric from was brought
up
since is usually the person i see least
referred to
as a prominent member of the frankfurt
school and i actually have always found
his work extremely informative and
interesting since
of all the major figures he's the only
one i could think of who actually
really was able to successfully pull off
at least
marginally a synthesis of
freud and marxism and something like the
sane society um i actually find that
book
a lot more cogent than even something
like eros and civilization so
here's the from uh maybe do our best to
actually
resuscitate his reputation well i mean
i don't know if i'd be that person i
mean uh from
you know in many ways differed from
marcusa
and adorno horkheimer and they sort of
rejected a lot of his ideas because he
he strayed from freudian theory uh
he you know rejected a lot of the core
freudian
um concepts about the psyche
um and instead sort of shifted more
towards
the existentialist thinkers um sartran
and those so he he's more of a melding
of
existentialism um and marxism then
i would say a melding of freud and marx
traitor i would certainly agree although
i don't think that he's ever he ever
actually was shy away from that because
he acknowledged
it a number of points that he thought
marx was a far more important particular
than
somebody like freud right and the kind
of analytic that he took from freud was
more about this idea
from my uh like in my imagination that
the psyche always is distorted
and it tends to act out as distortions
and symptoms and sometimes
extraordinarily anti-social ways via the
authoritarian personality and stuff but
we should probably wait to get into that
there's also a few curve balls out there
with
the the actual publication history
of marx's texts so stay with me
listeners but
but like like the grundrissa like
marx's other sort of major late work and
those 1844
humanist manuscripts they were done a
bit earlier in marx's life
1844 in fact uh those were not published
until the 1930s so you also have this
like dynamic where
like different texts by marks are
becoming available
at different points in the 20th century
as well
which makes it really confusing to sort
of follow the critical theory
and the development of or the way they
use marx
because these texts are popping up and
and this is just
in german too like the grunderson wasn't
even translated into english until what
like the 1960s or 70s and
the 1844 manuscripts weren't available
in english until much later as well
like there's some weird textual history
going on there you have to look it up
so the english and the english usually
are they're very um
pious so they had a problem problems
with
publishing research notes that's my hype
yeah i think that um you know marcuso
was one of the
early people to start commenting i
believe he reviewed
the economic manuscripts
when they were published and he was one
of the first people to really start to
use that early those early marx writings
and they're really important for
critical theory generally
because those are writings where they're
talking a lot about alienation
and they're talking a lot about marx is
talking a lot about
the effect of culture on our material
existence
and so those are key ideas that you see
with
the early frankfurt school at least
which is that um
you know instead of just focusing on a
sort of vulgar marxism where it's
purely economic they are dealing now
with
the ways that culture affects our
material life
those public that publication history is
is important like eric said
yeah and you get these later guys too
that come to marx like uh
altazer and etienne balbar and i'm not
sure if this goes for etienne
balabar as well but but but um
alphazer really just rejected the
earlier marxist works like he just
did not like marxist humanism at all
he just divided marx up into like three
stages
said the late stage was the the best and
most mature
and most like comprehensive stage [ __ ]
the other ones
and he was just hardcore structural
marxist so
so i guess the point is like big
disagreements within
everyone who's looking at marks and
reading marks nobody can
nobody can get along nobody can really i
mean that's it's a good thing in a way
because you have all these different
perspectives and takes
and there's no unified front really and
then at the whole time you had the more
politically engaged marxists and
the leninist marxists and then you had
the sort of old-school idealist hegelian
marxists
i mean it's a mess we'll work it out a
little bit today okay
let me let me try to establish a little
bit of a plan um
the the boys here have divided up
the texts um
eric having read a dork i read marcusa
and matt having done habermas if i'm not
mistaken
shaolin you're the heavyweight sorry the
intellectual heavyweight here
so we didn't give you anything we didn't
give you an assignment
so you can be the glue that weaves our
disparate narratives together but
continuing from last week again
this is a where psychoanalysts
psychoanalysis psychoanalysis
and marxism are very much fused
and generally the reason for that in our
narrative here is
that um you know so much of europe
was poised it seemed to turn to marxism
in the 1930s america as well with
organized labor movements and yet
they turned to uh fascism
and then later during the 50s during
this marshall plan reconstruction
very much into state capitalism with
the marshall plan and keynesian
economics so i think the purpose of
recruiting
freud in here is to try to explain why
people
opt into market relationships that don't
benefit them
and even that harm them in the case of
fascism
and also to understand the psychological
effects
of say in odorino's case the culture
industry
on the people who are sort of captured
by it right like there's that sort of
deep psychological level that
freud provided some resources or tools
to sort of describe
the idea of the superego for example as
as like
internalizing rules and regulations
and just just various like ideas about
depth psychology
and how to describe society with
and also filled out sort of
psychological theory as well
i would also say like the text
civilization and his discontents right
in the aftermath of the first world war
was probably the most important
formative influence on the frankfurt
school
because i mean freud even in that text
acknowledges that this is very
speculative uh
which coming from freud really means
something right but uh oddly enough i
actually find it one of his more
imaginative texts and he's really taking
a stab
at social psychology and some of the
ruminations he comes up with
are shocking and provocative and the
best possible yeah i agree with that too
i think it's one of the great texts and
uh
that is a really influential one on the
um
on the frankfurt school and it like you
said matt
it's also where freud kind of
becomes more of a philosopher of culture
rather than
strictly a um psychoanalyst
but um so what eric was saying with you
know the culture industry
i mean i think that the inclusion of
freud
is important at this point in time for
the frankfurt school because you have
both the culture industry which
is gaining dominance and control over
society in new ways
um but also you have the frankfurt
school looking at
the psychological effects of fascism so
you have people like willem reich
or reich um and uh who is exploring
fascism from a psychological angle
and you know where you have people
who've analyzed fascism from
you know neumann that we we talked about
earlier um
looked at fascism in his book behemoth
um
where he looked at more of the political
side of fascism and you have
marxists who have looked at fascism from
a marxist
economic perspective but the frankfurt
school were really kind of the first
people to
look at fascism and see you know what
kind of makes up the psyche of someone
who
becomes a fascist now they're not of
course saying that this these are the
only reasons but it is
supplemental it's it's an it's a
compliment
to um the already existing marxist
theories about the rise of fascism
so i'll just plug in for that too that
there's a lot of misunderstanding
about the way that they use freud
uh i came across some quotes actually of
habermas being a little condescending
towards the earlier frankfurt school
just saying that all freud was was just
he just allowed them to use this
mechanism of internalization
from freud and that's all he was good
for in these earlier what he calls
freudo marxists but really
really they they have a theory about the
way that capitalism
shapes so one of the key things about
marxism in the frankfurt school is that
they felt it lacked the theory of the
subject
and freud also sort of helped give birth
to this
this theory of the subject and the way
that individuals are already
shaped by capitalist ideology
is it's a it's also a psychological
system
that produces a certain kind of
subjectivity and they're not just
talking about the ways that certain
things become internalized although
that's part of it i guess but that's
a very simplistic reading of the way
that the early frankfurt school guys
used freud courtesy of pabermas who's
great but he also
isn't right about everything just
because the second generation leader
although he's very bright yeah
yeah there's no doubt about that uh i
just want to interject and say one thing
in response to that
not to defend habermas because i think
he's actually wrong on this point yeah i
agree with jesus criticism
uh of him on this uh but long story
short
uh what habermas is doing is actually
insisting that the problem with
appealing to freud was precisely the
fact that he grants his theory of
subjectivity
and reintegrates the philosophy of the
subject uh
into marxist theory uh when what he's
trying to do is move away from the
philosophy of the subject
towards a communicative pragmatic
orientation
and he feels that freud was sometimes
you know
a good contribution to that but also
tended to
recalcify certain hardened expectations
that
the frankfurt schoolers would have been
better off moving away from
right so it is more than just
condescension right there's actually a
kind of
philosophical disagreement about what
their subjectivity should be
placed at the epicenter of critical
theory
and we're talking about how they're
using freud and using freud's
subjectivity but if we could just
specify this a little bit i'll start
because i have
at least one way and that's with the
concept of repression so
repression for freud is
you have a desire as soon as that desire
is repressed
for example in the edible complex as
soon as it's repressed it's going to act
out in different ways it's going to be a
symptom for
neuroses or violence
or disassociation in some way or
projection
and one way that at least marcusa
who i read today uses this is saying
that
um your your creativity is repressed in
your leisure time
because capitalism isn't just happy
taking your work time and taking that
from you
it also wants to shove a bunch of
products into your leisure time
so that your actual ability to be
creative
is then repressed throughout your whole
life is there any others
um specific concepts from freud that get
deployed here
yeah so i mean two things on that one um
this is also where marcusa just to note
this is also where marcusa
begins to sort of differ from people
like adorno and horkheimer
at least early horkheimer um because
when you look at adorno's critiques of
the culture industry
those use more marks than freud i would
argue
the culture industry essentially
creates these sorts of forms of
catharsis
that make us sort of passive
and we won't want to revolt against the
system
um so there's very much a marxist
critique
of the culture industry from adorno when
you get to marcusa
um and he starts to sort of
differ in his uh interpretation of freud
he is dealing more with repression at
the more individual
level so that um whereas the freudians
before would seek to balance out the ego
marcusa is wanting to sort of boost up
the id um boost up the
our animal instincts the things that we
want to do but we're repressed because
of
whatever reasons uh you know societal
reasons psychological reasons whatever
um and this is why marcus ended up being
a key figure for the new left in the
1960s because
the new left started to sort of shift
away from an old form of marxism
that focused mostly on mass organizing
mass organization of the working class
towards
a kind of liberation of the self
which we we always remember in the 60s
but actually came out
especially more so in the 70s um
and marcuzzo was sort of their hero
because he was
trying to uh get people to get rid of
these
this sense of uh repression um
so that they could free up their id this
is why he became a very big influence on
people like norman o'brown and some of
these other
psychoanalysts and cultural critics
later on
but this is also where he kind of
differs from
adorno where adorno's making a much more
marxist critique
of the culture industry um marcus is
making a more freudian critique of the
culture industry i would argue yeah
that's true
can i just ask a quick question um
just because like uh we have discussed
nietzsche and heidegger at some length
before
uh and we haven't really dived very
deeply into heidegger's theory of
authenticity and its association with
fascism and so on
but could you explain like what
differentiates uh marcus's idea of
liberating
the id from heideggerian ideas of
authenticity
or being your true self if you want to
use the more colloquial term
and i say this also because for
historical reasons uh it's pretty
controversial since of course heidegger
was
a formative influence on the earlier
mercury's yeah you know i don't know i'm
kind of
um that would be a question for somebody
else because i don't know too much about
heidegger in that regard
i know that marcusa you know studied
heidegger and tried to like sort of
meld heidegger and marks but i don't
know much about that
okay i can wager to answer that in terms
of um
one of the sort of controversial things
about
about heidegger is his sense of
rootedness
and also the sense of getting away from
the of technological sort of
cosmopolitan
life um and i think that comes out in
marcusa because marcus
very is very preoccupied with leisure
time
and what you do with your leisure time
so whereas
a lot of marx's theory deals with labor
time
and how labor itself is alienated
and leisure time is part of
marx's theory as well because he says
like in leisure you only become an
animal basically because you're tired of
having worked all day
and this this lines up with heidegger's
uh sort of retreat
phase because he was banned from
teaching
but his retreat phase in saying like the
the authentic
is to create spaces for thinking
and one of the things you have to do to
think is be bored
not have a bunch of products to consume
a bunch of media
to consume constantly so um this is like
the cabin the cabin in the woods
heidegger fits up very well with
marcus's thoughts about using your
leisure time to be creative but
for it to be creative you have to not be
in a rat race the rest of the day trying
to increase your profit and get
get product basically
yeah i don't want to take a swing at
that i don't know like heidegger has his
own version of alienation right which
has to do with
with being alienated from authentic
being
and being sort of captured by the uh
the crowd or dosmann right so we're all
radical in this like radically fallen
state and yeah that's like i i have
nothing prepared to talk about
heidegger in this context because i mean
he's he's
like adorno criticizes heidegger like he
he just seems radically incompatible
with what we're going to be talking
about in a way
well that's the reason i brought him up
and i mean we don't have to pursue this
line of inquiry because i'm sure that
there's more interesting things to talk
about it's just um
there was a big controversy i think in
the 1930s uh
since markus acknowledged the fact that
he was highly influenced by heidegger
and then heidegger was a nazi
and unlike adorno uh who was almost
immediately and scathingly critical
uh of the whole heideggerian apparatus
uh
marcus you know ever after displayed
some kind of sympathy
uh to the project of existential
analysis which is why you know there's
controversies and
inquiries and to the extent
of this influence right all right before
we took this
divergence i was asking about freud and
no one brought it up so i'll throw it to
you after i
bring it up but the concept of ideology
and not the concept that people use
today actually i have an anecdote about
this and that one of my committee
members while i was writing my
dissertation
pretty much said outright i am not
allowed to use the word ideology
because it's too confused and i would
have to spend
too much time defining it i did anyway
but um ideology does not just mean the
political beliefs that you choose
especially for the frankfurt school it
means the political beliefs
that you don't choose so in reference to
marcusa
um his the ideology that he focuses on
is that we already do enough work
that we could stop working like if
everyone worked two hours a day
in an economy that has this much
money um we'd all be fine you wouldn't
have all the
all the goods to consume you wouldn't
have all the luxury goods and products
but if everyone just did their two hours
you'd pretty much have enough
and the ideology for him is that you
always have to be growing
profit and increasing profit
and yeah that's a fetish like he thinks
you should just like draw a line almost
and stop working at a certain point so
in terms of ideology where you add uh
fetishes in in marx or freud's
terms this is one of the words on which
they both align if you add fetishes
to your actions then how does that play
out in like political life
ideologically i was just going to bring
up
that that when we talk about fetish
uh with marks we're talking about
commodity fetishism
so in in the way we forget
that everyday products like our clothing
or you can go you can this was actually
touched on in uh
pills's uh marx alienation video but
it's fetishism is kind of the way we
forget that there's like a modicum of
labor that goes into everything that we
use
all the products that we buy and
everything that that is all
say objectified labor
by the laboring class who are being
exploited under capitalism right
and when we fall under the spell of
uh of commodity fetishism we we sort of
forget that that is what is happening
all around us
everything everything is built by
somebody everything is made by somebody
everything is invested
whereas invested in by people's labor
and time
whereas with the freudian
version of of fetishism i don't know if
this word helps but cathaxis
it's it's kind of it means kind of um
the investment of libidinal energy like
when you have like a keepsake
or something you just don't want to
throw away because it has too much
sentimental value
like that's that's a cathexis that's a
that's the investment of some kind of
psychic energy into something
and i think that has to do with
fetishism but also
it has a sexual meaning too right like
if you want to explain like a foot
fetish
yeah like that that is also a kind of
investment of libidinal energy
and it's displaced onto a certain object
so
supposedly at some point in your life
you had some kind of developmental issue
maybe you you didn't really complete the
anal phase properly or something like
that
and you you uh displace all this
sexual psychic energy onto some object
that well in the terms of not completing
the anal phase it means you become anal
retentive i guess i'm probably doing
some kind of horrible stereotype here
but you become anal retentive you become
a [ __ ] prude right that's how it
outworks kind of
yeah this is gonna cash out in the in
the culture industry stuff as well but
basically a fetish
in both cases a fetish has to do with a
partial object and the rest of that
object is supplemented by your desire
so there's a surplus desire for the
object that doesn't actually have to do
with it and we could talk about you know
branding and
you know i don't know luxury goods as
fetishized objects but the fetish just
means
you desire it more than there's any use
in the actual object
whether that's sexual or just like yeah
of course uh you know a status
[Music]
vital of course
also anthropological too is where both
of them are getting that
um that phrase but
i would say that the culture industry is
probably the
you know i know this is what i always go
back to but it is such a good example
of you know this this kind of idea
because you have um well you know in
marcus's
um point of view um you have this kind
of
objectification that marx talks about
under capitalism
um where people sort of begin to
see themselves um
as like extensions of the objects that
they're producing
like they they sort of
see themselves as the objects that
they've been sort of forced to
produce um and it and capitalism sort of
creates this sense of
false needs um you know and this of
course plays into the culture industry
as well
um so that you feel like you have to
have
all these things that the culture
industry provides you i mean
this is kind of the phenomenon to give
an example
um you know when you see all these
people who get excited about like every
new
shitty marvel movie or whatever you know
and people even know that they're [ __ ]
you know but they like have to watch
them they have they like
have to consume because it's like they
they they feel like they have to um
even if they don't even like them um so
you get this sort of sense that
um there are these needs that people
feel that need to be met
and this is again where this this the
psychology of it comes into play
i mean how the culture industry
manipulates our psychology
because it always supports capitalism in
the end and this is
another aspect of the culture industry
that i think people sort of miss
um because they'll say oh you know like
can't some good art squeeze through the
culture industry um
and um well sure like there can be good
stuff that squeezes through
but that's sort of missing the point um
the point is that the culture industry
has one goal
um not a main goal but one goal which is
profit um and if your main goal is
profit
again put in another way to um prop
up capitalism um then you're you're
always going to be
limited in you know how how good the art
can be
and you're always going to be
manipulated by the industry to make you
think that you need the things that you
don't
um but you feel like you do i'm just
going to switch things around
uh for two seconds to talk about the
production side of things uh in true
marxist fashion right since we should
always talk about productive processes
uh by suggesting this isn't some kind of
conspiratorial effort on the part of
the capitalist class to brainwash or
delude
uh the lower classes by up in the pull
up hockey and lottery uh
looking lottery games and marvel films
right
uh you know these people may very
sincerely feel that they're invested in
producing a product and this will
produce a certain degree of happiness
but nonetheless it has this structural
effect
of diminishing a desire for reform
by satisfying true human needs but
sometimes this is misinterpreted this
way
right in the sense that there's this
giant cultural industry
organized by walt disney and they meet
in some kind of
dark castle in transylvania and they say
this is how we're going to loot the
lower classes and that's not what this
is about
yeah it's an accidental confluence of
we could call this like a systems theory
pretty much it's an accidental
confluence of a
million little decisions being made for
the sake of profit that eventually
turns into a situation where
um revolution is almost the most
unimaginable consequence
of this right because needs that you
don't even know
you've ever had are being met before you
even have them and then
you're too exhausted to ever you know
pick up your placard and
storm the best deal yeah one example
that i really liked was um
the commodification of technology in the
early 21st century
so people would sometimes ask like well
why is it that there's an iphone
5 an iphone 6 an iphone 7 and what are
actually the differences between each of
these and
if you actually were to interrogate it
there's not really a substantial
difference between
each of these generations but what
somebody like steve jobs was very
successfully able to do
was create a need to be at the cutting
edge
of a technological revolution as you
play you don't want to miss an episode
you can't you can't binge a show you're
missing an episode
and of course you know if a donor would
hear it say well being at the cutting
edge of this quote technological
revolution means of course that you'll
never actually engage in
genuinely revolutionary activity which
would mean changing
the mode of production to establish a
more egalitarian
uh society where real needs are able to
be met right mm-hmm
yeah so just to say i don't like the
iphone you know
if apple is listening right i do take
endorsements yeah
so that's basically the there's
there's a couple different there's two
different kinds of there's human needs
first of all there's that kind of need
where what you need to survive
so when the capitalist class is running
their factories they know exactly
how much money their workers need to
survive and support their family and get
enough calories per day to
live on but within the culture industry
it seems like to me that it's the
creation of this
new like area of need where
it's the need for consumption because
what the capital industry
does is it turns us into consumers we're
not just workers anymore
making a living we're now all also
consumers
they make us into almost like employees
in a way
i mean adorno talks about talent scouts
and the way that the culture industry
absorbs talent
but we also are made into consumers
which marx points out is actually one of
the areas of production
there's there's like three areas of
production right there's
there's the sort of extraction and
manufacturing there's distribution and
there's consumption
those are the sorts of three areas of
production so it's kind of weird to
think about consumption as
as production but that's the that's the
end
of the life cycle right before the
garbage can i guess
of any product so we
are turned into consumers and then on
that basis
they need to create needs which we need
to
compulsively fill fulfill by
i don't know buying magazines i mean his
biggest
examples are yeah film magazines
radio and these sorts of new mass media
forms
and i should add that this isn't an
argument for asceticism right
it's not like marcusa and adorno are
saying that what we should do is
embrace some kind of stoic philosophy
where we realize that we don't actually
need all this crap
and then go sit in a commune
dissociating ourselves from the world
what they're saying is that the problem
with the way that the capitalist system
and the culture industry
organizes uh the production of means is
that
we have genuine desires uh that aren't
being fulfilled
um they're being commodified
and we're giving a cheap iteration of
what it is that we really want
uh so for example people really want
genuine connection
uh with other people particularly like
romantic partners but let's just
use other people in general right and
they're unable to get that because
they're working 12
14 uh hours a day uh if you add up labor
time at the home and so on and so forth
uh and to compensate for that fact
people will watch romantic movies
about the man getting the girl and how
happy he is and everyone in the movie
never seems to have to work because
they're always hanging out at the cafe
and dealing with each other's drama
uh and what a doran would say is the
movie has a real insight to it right
which is that people want human
connection
but rather than telling you how it is
that you genuinely achieve it which
would be
by transforming the conditions under
which you live which would allow you to
spend more time with those people that
you love and you care about
uh it's giving you a cheap substitute
for it which is just
seek romantic love under the conditions
of lake capitalism make sure you have
enough money that you can have plenty of
leisure time
and everything will be fine right so
it's not an argument for asceticism
which is what i think sometimes people
interpret adorno uh and poor primer
especially is saying right that
we should all stop wanting things it's
an argument for the fact that
we aren't getting what we want out of
capitalism what we're getting is the
mick uh substitute for we're paying for
further
unhappiness yeah no i was just gonna
agree with you matt um and and just
uh say that um you know people often
think of adorno as an elitist which is a
completely wrong way to think about him
um you know because what he's actually
saying
is one like you pointed out earlier the
culture industry is a structural problem
you can't you can't work within the
culture industry you can't work within
capitalism
to fix the problems of capitalism the
only
solution to these problems is appending
capitalism so
you know he's making a very marxist
argument it's not elitist at all
uh in fact it's the opposite of that um
for for adorno
like we are not reaching our true
potential as individuals
because um this the
the oversight of capitalism completely
dominates our lives
and the second point um to what you were
saying
is that uh and uh you know pills can
probably say more about
the notion of catharsis but the culture
industry
specifically gives us ideas about
revolution to pacify us so
one of the most recent examples is
things like that joker movie
um you know where you know people are
like oh look this is like such a
revolutionary movie it's it's
you know got all these revolutionary
themes which you know i watched it and
you know it i guess had some light
revolutionary themes i guess um but you
could also say they were reactionary
they just kind of were hollywood in my
opinion but
um but that's a perfect example of how
the industry feeds us little bits
of like oh look we know that the system
sucks
so let me um as the culture industry let
me give you some
stuff to uh make you feel feel like
you're participating
in um resistance against the system
by participating in this entertainment
industry product
um and you know like i said pills can
probably talk a little bit more about
the nature of catharsis
and and how that works within all this
i was going to turn it to eric since i
interrupted him
oh yeah well i was hoping for other
people to
respond to this i'll just throw this out
there okay and say
the main difference between since we're
on the topic of aesthetics
say adorno and marcusa so
adorno's version of aesthetics is
okay yes he did get rejected
maybe in the 60s by the 70s
as a kind of elitist because
he did enjoy writers like kafka
and insanely complex composers like
schoenberg and berg who he was friends
with
and this is because adorno's version of
aesthetics is
a kind of bourgeois aesthetics not not
bourgeois aesthetics but
the autonomy of the work of art the work
of art needs to provide
a space in which the contradictions
of real life which the culture industry
does not
allow to be worked out to their full
completion it does
not allow for what do you call it
sublation
because as adorno says in his freudian
moments
the culture industry does not sublate
it represses right it shows you
boobs and nice nice uh torsos of heroic
people
and it it it just those unsublimated
desires it plays with them so adorno
says
you need a sort of separate autonomous
space in which art can work out these
contradictions in a certain way whereas
marcusa
he gets picked up in the 1968 student
revolutions especially in germany
because marcus's philosophy is seen as
more friendly to popular art
and to the way that we're gonna find
sublation
in real life we need to integrate art
into the movement itself
into real life and that's sort of the
difference between marcus and adorno
adorno has this idea that art does need
to be a little bit
autonomous whereas marcusa
is all for you know art
as a kind of well he has
he has this theory of of happiness and
arrows
and the way that arts should not present
an illusion world in which cultural
ideals
ideals are shown no that that should be
in real life
art should feed movements and be
something that we really
like have you know if i'm if i'm a part
of a movement maybe we'll have our
representative artists who produce our
pamphlets
and our images and our memes and
everything and those go into the
struggle
whereas for adorno no there's an
autonomous realm of art which presents
us with these nice cultural ideals
and we can actually see them in all
their contradictions and all of their
workings out and that's where sublation
happens because
ablation does not happen in the
culture industry that's where repression
happens
if you want to talk about drive theory i
think i can unify this
with the catharsis angle is that
it with drives drives seek a certain
satisfaction
so you feel driven to eat because you're
hungry and that reduces the tension
inside your body or you get horny so
you have to reduce that tension by
getting laid
and this if we're gonna like blow up
freud's
theories to a macro level we could talk
about joker
or black panther as they respond
to like this this intensity this tension
and they're like oh the oscars are too
white for you okay we'll make
we'll we'll give you this black panther
movie then it wins the oscars or
you feel like there's social alienation
that you need to
respond to there's angst and like like
you said charlotte it's like
unclear who the joker is for
is it for leftists is it for in cells
no it's just for anyone who feels like a
vague sense of alienation
doesn't know what to do with it we're
going to give you this
to know that you're being heard but
you're going to pay for it also
and this contrasts with adorno's theory
of art which is no we want to leave you
in dissonance we want to leave you not
knowing what to do so that you can walk
away from whatever it is you're walking
away from
and still feel that angst maybe you even
get a more cute
sense of angst well actually i'd like to
build on that by just saying one thing
in response to eric which is that
what he is also opposed to is
reactionary responses to the
contradictions
of late capitalism right uh which is
something like what heidegger would
propose right because
you can look at movies like say no
country for old men or into the wild
and what they involve are typically male
protagonists who retreat from society
and it's vulgarity to try to discover
their true self
or to get what it is that they want and
these movies you know
are reactionary uh in the sense that
they don't actually have any kind of
revolutionary potential it's about
the individual deciding that this world
is so radically fallen that there's no
point in actually trying to even invest
yourself in into any longer so anything
to do is withdraw
and look after yourself and try to
rediscover some kind of spiritual
element in your personal life
and i don't think that's what adorno
would approve of right what he wanted
was
a revolutionary kind of art that allowed
you to connect
your alienation or your sense of enemy
to a broader struggle for
collective emancipation or social
emancipation depending on how you want
to frame it which is why we have to be
really careful
and saying that just because something
is genuinely a work of art that doesn't
mean it can't be a reactionary piece of
art
right yes and and to add to that um
to both what eric and matt said um
adorno is um
i'll just sort of tweak one thing that
eric said which is that
you know you mentioned how he was sort
of into bourgeois art i would
say that he was um we kind of look
back at classical music now and sort of
think of it as one sort of homogeneous
thing unless you're someone who's into
music theory and history
um it kind of seems that way but it's
not all bourgeois art um so like adorno
was actually into modernist art
and schoenberg one of the reasons he
liked schoenberg
is because that he was
a radical challenge to tradition
in music theory um and
he there's a there's a great essay that
adorno wrote where he's
comparing stravinsky who was originally
a radical um composer
and then became more of a popular
composer
over time that became very nationalist
and comparing him to schoenberg
and he's talking about what's really
important for adorno is that art
remain radical and so you'll see like he
often changes opinions on on composers
over historical time not because
his not because of um reasons of
aesthetics
but because of reasons um that they
no longer were acting revolutionary in
the composition of their
works another thing i'll just sort of
note too
um on the topic of art is that you know
i saw
some comments on the culture industry
video
um you know people were saying look what
about
movies like sorry to bother you which um
you know i really like sorry to bother
you it's it was made by boots riley
who's who is a communist
um but i think a lot this sort of is
this example is sort of a
um example of how the culture industry
has permeated our lives so much that
people think that everything that's a
film or music comes out of the culture
industry
sorry to bother you as an example was
not a culture industry product it was an
independent film
um and it got very lim because it was an
independent film it got very limited
uh theater play um and
limited distribution and so forth um so
that film was able to be revolutionary
and have anti-capitalist themes
um because it was not a product of the
culture industry so
there are still ways for art to
work outside of the culture industry
it's just incredibly
difficult because the culture industry
dominates um
everything and just one last point about
that
which is that you know when we're
talking about the culture industry we're
not just talking about hollywood
or you know sony you know the big films
the big
um music labels and so forth um we're
also talking
about news media news used to be
separate from a profit-making endeavor
ever since the 70s um media has come
under the influence of corporate control
now media
is concentrated news media is
concentrated to
five or six companies it changes every
now and then but
um five or six companies that own all of
you know 90 of news media and i'm not
talking about alternative press
and americans should be proud of their
seven companies that they have
right so um this is this is how it like
i'll finish up but like this is how the
culture industry
sort of maintains these ideological
um notions uh is because
these sorts of ideas are you know
in tandem with um with
the news and where we get our
information about politics where we get
our information about the world around
us
um so they work together and there's a
very intimate relationship between them
yeah i just want to say i think people
mainly accuse a dorner of being elitist
because they figured if they had a copy
of like a beatles record or something
you would just come in and smash it
right
how dare you own abby rogue [ __ ] that
please please me go please your [ __ ]
boss [ __ ]
yeah yeah and even though we have
alternative news sources like uh i don't
know podcasts
on both the right and left like [ __ ]
fox news gets 2 million views a day
compared to even the most popular
podcast which might get like
what is it joe rogan yeah he'll get a
million
on a on a video over like a month or two
i guess
i mean like hbo and netflix both have
they have their their last week tonight
and their their patriot act and
they often like [ __ ] on their capitals
that own them
right like i i consider those to be like
sort of semi-independent but
i think when like adorno yeah one of the
later critiques is yeah they didn't
really predict these like independent
value spheres that could emerge within
the culture industry at the point
they're writing
it's really when culture has just become
like since before world war one a little
really just
integrated into this totalizing system
and
he does say they do say that cult like
cultural monopolies are weak
the culture industry does not have
ideological control
unless it's backed by whom by
big steel by chemical by petroleum
and by electricity those are the those
are the industrial monopolies that
support the existence of the culture
industry
and you can think of this in terms of
even today the koch brothers
have a huge stake in getty images so
every time
you use an image from getty images you
think you're just using a stock
image but no you're using something that
the koch brothers own
and they really keep an eye on that [ __ ]
and you got to pay the money every time
you use
a stock image from getty images so it's
it's not that just the cap the culture
industry exists
like there's a material base for that
and that is
big steel oil chemical and electricity
right so
those things are ever present today in
our society as well
they have an overbearing presence over
everything
and so even though there's independent
value spheres that emerge and
and subcultures the legacy of the 60s
we also still have that same underlying
material base
that enable all this stuff to happen
like where do the wires come from where
do all the materials come from like
we're an independent value sphere just
right here but i'm sure the things that
i bought that let me do this are owned
by
people i would not want to give my money
to but i have to anyway
and so i can produce some kind of nice
counter culture
dialogue with my money that i gave to
bill gates or to whatever who
whoever fill in whatever semi
conspiratorial family rich name you want
but i i think you hit on a really good
point about this and i would actually
just broaden it further by saying that
one of the things that the cultural
industry
according to adorno um and like his uh
later figures like mark fisher
what it does that's so effective is it's
able to co-opt a lot of revolutionary
forms of art
and analyze them i can't remember who
actually coined that term it might have
been fisher right
uh and therefore like kind of gut them
of revolutionary potential and again
this isn't a conscious activity
uh it's something that savvy marketers
are just really good at right they sit
there and they say oh the youth of today
are actually getting really riled up by
this
so why don't we take it and transform it
into something that's a little bit more
commercial
and i remember shalon did a really good
presentation for my class maybe about a
year and a half ago
when she talked about this right and so
i won't steal the examples but just one
that i sometimes think about
because i'm a big fan is like punk music
right you think about the clash and joy
division
and a lot of the early bands you know
the sex pistols that had
really revolutionary working class rage
behind them
uh and you take that and you transform
it into angry sounding music for the
youth
uh by the time the mid 80s comes along
and all of a sudden is transformed into
anthems that people will pay big dollars
uh in order to go you know enjoy it
right as a kind of supplement uh to
capitalism or as a substitute for
genuine uh revolutionary activity
depending on how you interpret it right
yeah i mean it's really i think it's
perfect yeah looking at
um punk and hip hop
um as good examples of how the culture
industry co-ops
um counter-cultural movements i mean
both punk and hip-hop started
as independent cult forms of cultural
rebellion
um but it was not long before
uh you know advertisers and the music
industry
realized their um potential for profit
making
and completely essentially bought them
up and you know we see this
kind of throughout the the history of of
mute of 20th century music especially
um and you know adorno's always given a
hard time i have to say it adorn is
always given a hard time about
his takes on jazz um but
you know people who kind of
misunderstand that don't really
understand either the music theory or
the music history there
uh you know when when adorno's talking
about um
jazz he's he's saying that he's
referring to the popular dance form of
music
that existed you know in the 1940s um
which you know this is a time when
you know this isn't the jazz that people
think of when they think of jazz it's
not cool jazz
and bebop that came you know later in
the 50s
um when adorno's talking about this he's
talking about
music like glenn miller and lawrence
welk and
jazz music that had been completely
standardized and 100
became formulaic um and
it was being picked up by the
um culture industry that was forming at
this time and you have
the music industry um like ascap
bmi that pretty much owns most of music
those got their form uh those formed in
like 1940
abouts um so you know you see this
throughout
all of the 20th century music and
especially into the 21st century where
you'll see pockets of cultural rebellion
and that seems sort of promising but
then the culture industry being the
behemoth that it
is um quickly can um take these up
and use them for their own purposes or
even to use the example you gave earlier
on joker right i mean like
you have martin scorsese movies and
other kind of uh
new way films in the 1970s that i would
say at their best did genuinely have
some revolutionary potential right you
think about taxi driver
as a kind of anti-vietnam war credo uh
analyzing the kind of depression that
results uh from being in this
highly nixonite society right uh and
then you know it had a little bit of
political heft to it
uh and then you take that and you
transport it into 2019
and all of a sudden what you're just
given is revolution about nothing
right you're just angry so here's a
figure who can act as an anti-signifier
for you to eject all your animosities
into
uh and hey it's also a pop culture
figure so you know him you're familiar
with him and he's a relatively
comfortable person to do that with right
oh and it made billions of dollars by
the way yeah
as opposed to travis bickle where you
sit there and you think you know green
beret
working a blue collar job goes crazy and
kills a bunch of people that's a really
uncomfortable person to actually have to
think through these dynamics with right
which is part of what makes that movie
relatively provocative so if we can get
back to
i mean we just did i think we covered
the culture industry there but
and actually you know what this sounds
like a conspiracy theory right it sounds
like
oh marxism didn't work so now we're
gonna go find psychoanalysis because we
our theory has to be right about this
behemoth thing
anyway we've we've done some shaolin
we've done some work before about how
we sound like conspiracy theorists if we
were listening to ourselves from the
outside but
back to the marxist thrust of this whole
thing the whole marxist thrust the way i
see it
anyway is this is a theory of
why do we have so much and yet
we're unhappy i think at bottom that's
what all of them are trying to address
um and as opposed to someone like
stephen pinker who's like
africa is making four dollars a day now
like this is a
improvement you know so marcus
says something basically like if this
were a rational system
we would have stopped over producing a
long time ago
because we already had enough we already
have enough to be happy and now
the overproduction the surplus is just
making us more unhappy
by the way if you want to know more
about marcusa i got a shout out to
my friend on youtube
epoch philosophy who just released a
video on it um i didn't finish it so i
can't vouch for the whole thing but i
can vouch for the first half
anyway the title is great
philosophy um so
yeah like the idea that marcusa has and
i think the rest of them
sort of generally with this culture
industry stuff is
if this were a rational system in the
way that we kind of think of
capitalism being rational and the
arguments that are made for capitalism
being rational like look it's better for
everybody it's not producing happiness
in the end so i was wondering what you
of what you guys read today and shall
and what you've read your entire life
our your entire your entire career i
should say
from the cradle she was kicking me out
of
negative dialectics being like oh this
is my future
my parents were just spoon feeding her
being like yeah
so shelland until she read negative
dialectics for the first time
[Music]
um i was just wondering what like in in
terms of applying marxism
today um and the way they do it and the
way
we've tried to do it and the way other
people have done it what do they speak
to in terms of like human happiness and
what would a good system look like and
what are the things that we're missing
and we're doing critical theory but how
do we go just beyond
like whining about the music industry
and and things like that this whole
thing is [ __ ]
it it's like we're i think he says it
somewhere
it's like we're the first society that
has the capability
i mean like the 21st 20th century
capitalist society
it's the first society that has the
capability of say like ending
world hunger and we just [ __ ] don't
do it
like we're so deep in this ideology that
it's not good for business it's not it
doesn't it doesn't conform to the profit
motive of the culture industry so we
just don't [ __ ] do it
and instead we make movies about it
because those make money
so that's a great [ __ ] thought i mean
when you come out of adorno and
horkheimer you just have this
complete pessimism there's not there's
nothing you can [ __ ] do what do you
do like okay i can point the way
but that's not gonna happen cool i make
art
and it resolves tensions in an
autonomous sphere
is that ever gonna be operationalized no
but
if you want to use it to study the
history of culture
this this is an amazing framework for
like asking questions about 20th century
industrial capitalism
but the the second wave critical
theorists definitely try to do this
right i mean we might not like their
answers we can be very critical of this
but like it'd be hard you'd be
hard-pressed to say that like axel
our second and third wave i should say
you'd be hard-pressed to say that like
copper mass or
axel haunted or shayla ben and b don't
have answers to these
problems right uh if anything most of
their career they've been trying to get
answers to these and the leftists hated
it
hated them for it so but i mean if it if
it's that easy then why don't we just do
it because that's that's the point well
matt this is kind of what i'm asking
what is that answer
if you can i would say that the answer
that logically follows from
this and i would say that um you know
even though he's not perceived this way
a close reading of his works will reveal
this is that the only answer to this is
a marxist solution which is revolution
revolution in the sense of uh not just
um you know pocketed rebellions
and insurrections but true revolution
that appends capitalism altogether
um and establishes a communist society
um so you know yes
they're the um at least you know the
early figures i
you know i'm not as well versed in the
later ones um but
the early figures do have a pessimistic
sense and it does seem sort of
doom um but but they're all right also
writing in like the best stage of
capitalism no one's going to revolt in
1950s usa
right right and well you say that martin
luther king did right
um yeah i shouldn't say i shouldn't say
1950s usa was good for everybody
but you know marshall plan keynesian
economics oil boom
business was good fair enough
yeah i mean i would not consider the
civil rights movement
um the kind of communist revolution that
um
you know marxist would would consider a
true revolution i mean
you know it was good it changed a lot of
the legal
um aspects but um you know
if you study the civil rights period you
see there were all these
ways that the government and everything
stopped
any sort of progresses and this is i
think goes to a point to today which is
that
when you have people who try to work
within capitalism like oh we can reform
capitalism
it's not going to work um you know the
only answer
is a sober one which is it needs
um mass organization um
to truly append capitalism
and um create a new system and what that
system looks like and
you know not exactly sure marx was not
clear on this either and he
uh you know even talked about how that's
the kind of thing
that you know those who change the
society
can um determine so in in terms of
happiness i don't know the answer to
that question i think humans are sort of
inherently unhappy regardless
of time period but uh in terms of
um living a life that
you know where you have food and shelter
and
um you're not worked to death like a
wage slave
um that requires revolution and you know
the
adorno is at the end of the day a
marxist even though he
you know is sort of in the realm of
intellect
intellectual thought um you know that's
always in the background of
you know his criticisms he he saw
thinking about these things he saw
radical thought as
a radical move um that we first
have to um understand
the problems and understand um why
capitalism
is bad for all these reasons um
because we have to get rid of it
yeah that's why i say the theorists
they're primarily
doing a descriptive thing they're not
prescriptive
marx was descriptive he was not
primarily a prescription guy he's not
like this is what you do
he's like this is what's happening it's
description it's social theory
you're trying to theorize what's going
on because
a better understanding of the society
that you're in can lead to
more targeted action better you know
understanding like if we move these guys
are all about
reason right but there's different forms
of reason
there's the kind of instrumental
rationality that capitalism applies to
everything
and then there's a different form of
rationality rationally organized society
which could work for everybody
that they want to get at but it's not
it's not really enough to just talk
about it we have to
understand the conditions that we're
in before we can you know change them
in any meaningful way so who's going to
do it not it yeah
no i understand and this is where i'm
going to push back a little bit on
both of these comments because i
absolutely appreciate the task of
to use airstream describing society
rather than providing prescriptive
guidelines right
uh but i think that there's a problem
inherent within that which is that we
can't necessarily abscond ourselves from
the burdens of moral judgment
uh and involving ourselves in the
creative effort of trying to imagine
what a better society would be
and this is where i think like somebody
like noam chomsky or hyper mosque can be
helpful
not necessarily because we should take
their own specific solutions on board
but boots as they provide
models uh for how this project could be
undertaken
and where it might go off the rails
right and this is one of the things that
i think is interesting and also
problematic about the critical theory as
uh critical theory tradition as a whole
because a lot of the people
who took up the adornian challenge of
trying to imagine a post-capitalist
society
ultimately came to the conclusion that
there's really no way
of doing that right uh if you think
about somebody like
jurgen habermas like his solution in the
1980s was that
there's no way of actually overcoming
the problems engaged
involved in steering the market economy
uh through state or democratic action
so we just had to accept the persistence
of the market as a constant feature in
life
and settle for something like a social
democratic welfare state axel honeth was
a little bit more radical
in saying that we need to emphasize
something like social freedom
uh as the basis of a common life that we
create and share in common
but he never really was able to define
that with a great deal of specificity
beyond saying that this would be some
kind of 21st century socialism matt i
would
really love to hear your manifest
manifesto for habermasian
reform no no i don't think so i mean
what i endorse is something like liberal
socialism which is a little bit
different right
but what i'm just saying is that i do
think there's this hunger on the part of
critical theorists
uh to provide something more than just
descriptions
of why it is that the world if we want
to put it bluntly sucks right
uh but we're not exactly willing to do
that all that often and
many of the solutions that have been put
forward aren't really
all that radical break from what we've
seen before which is why i think a lot
of marxists criticize them
right but if people are going to
criticize them then the onus is on
people with radical inclinations to at
least provide some kind of prescriptive
guidelines on how things will be better
off
if we take more drastic steps to
overcome the status quo
if that makes sense what do you guys
think because i
i i really don't even want to step out
on a limb here but i was
like reading marcusa it seems like
something like
ubi would be a big step towards
people being able to use their leisure
time creatively because one of the
problems is like you don't
hand to mouth you're not going to spend
any of that time
investing in in things that cost money
beyond like netflix because it costs too
much to like
undertake a project but if there were
something like ubi
do you think that would not not not wage
a revolution but in some
case make the possibility of leisure
time be more valuable or be more
meaningful
well leisure time is work
in the culture industry it's just like
work you
you you go to work you go home
and then that's your leisure time but
what are you really doing you're just
like receiving the products of your
work as like a collective member of the
culture industry which you're a part of
you just basically you consume and then
you
get into this stage where it's like okay
i can [ __ ] deal with another day of
work
and then you go back to work and then
that's that's sort of like
leisure just becomes just like work it's
a recharge
practical work cycle yeah but if you if
you could make leisure creative
would that is that a step if we can just
make robots do all the factory jobs
say well i'm not opposed to something i
hate ubi but i think the fundamentally
marxist point here
still stands which is that what we don't
just want is leisure time what we want
to feel
is in control of the labor process
and the only way to actually achieve
that is through a democratization of
production
right and you don't get that from a ubi
right you don't get that by just saying
like well you can either receive money
or you can go into a workplace and
you'll still be exploited and there'll
still be people who are telling you what
to do
but you might happen to make a little
bit more money in those circumstances
this is where i think that marx was
really insightful right where he said
that
one of the problems with bourgeois
economists and even you know welfarist
economists
is that they only emphasize things like
redistribution right and how it is to
give
people the money to do what they want uh
one what's also fundamentally important
is looking at the production side of
things
and if we look there we realize that
people are still going to be exploited
and people are still not going to be in
charge of
producing the kinds of things that they
desire or do at least producing
things that have market value in a
democratic fashion and that's what we
need to challenge
right so i'll be in favor of a ubi
because i think that would be a big
improvement on things
but i definitely don't think it would
challenge the underlying problem
uh which is the fact that many of us
work for crappy bosses
and in crappy situations where we don't
feel in control of our actions
uh and if we're still going to spend
eight nine hours a day doing that
then not a lot's going to change by just
giving people the option to opt out
and live on 1600 a month all right uh we
only have a few minutes left so
i'm going to give the final word as long
as as long as you want
shaolin um oh no but we're gonna
you can wrap up the discussion tell us
bring us home
tell us what you hope for tell us what a
door no hope for
if not you
well i think that to wrap it up
i mean i think we have to be conscious
of things like the culture industry
of how things that i mean we
see i think an average i think the last
statistic i saw
was that the average person sees about 5
000 ads a day
so we are inundated with a day
yes wow um so we are inundated with
constant
pressures um to consume
uh and i think the first step is to just
sort of be aware of it
and that's where adorno can come in um
but we can't really stop there
and in my opinion um you know we need to
focus
on creating a mass workers party
and really organizing to
work towards changing this and um
you know if you want to start on a small
level on in thinking in terms of art
you can think about supporting
independent artists
um and i don't mean like quote-unquote
indie artists that are really just put
out by hollywood but i mean like
actual um independent art but you can't
just
consume your way out of these problems
these problems
um the very thing that you know
all of the at least the early uh
frankfurt school is talking about
is problems with capitalism and
you know they're the early ones were
marxist and
they were saying look capitalism causes
these problems
marxists in the past have talked about
the political and economic problems that
capitalism has caused
we're also looking at the cultural and
psychological problems that capitalism
causes
all right so now we know there are all
these things that
are problems with capitalism so what
next i think
what we have to think about as marxist
is
um how to unpinned it how to get rid of
it
and how to um move forward and i think
that's all i can really say
as what we can take away from critical
theory
all right eric and matt do you have
anything that's less than a minute
and i mean that uh and that's
that i really like the beatles and
whatever dorno says about them
i stand by at least every one of their
post-65 records
so that's my final statement on the
matter
i think cars bombs
and movies keep our society going around
so keep those things coming
uh cars bombs movies drive to school
give them your money they invest in the
weapons
and then go home and watch a movie so
are you saying like
michael bay is the ultimate producer
in our economy yeah or like
all hail avatar and the unfulfilled
promises of that [ __ ] movie
which there's gonna be like four more of
those i think or something like that so
they are starting 2022. yeah there's
gonna be an avatar movie a year
so i'm looking forward to more
unfulfilled culture industry promises
red letter media was the uh critical
theory of today
so there you go all right from eric
matt and pills we'd like to thank
shaolin
go to her site which i have linked if
you would like to see
uh more of her stuff now having heard
her
um thanks shannon for coming it was
great
thanks so much for having me i don't
know if i'm happier or sadder than when
we started
yes despite this being a product of
labor
actually free like i mean labor are
supported by the mass
of patrons um
anyway thank you very much eric matt
i will see you guys later and you guys
can hit your record button
[Music]
it
[Music]